agents the next Target to be rescued is
Jack Arnold the wife of Mel Arnold
however don't let that put you off Jack
holds a lot of valuable Intel that is
being extracted from the mobile EHD
server that was retrieved from Kenley
College since she has been gone we've
been struggling to access the server and
files have been going missing agents
it's imperative that we get it back as
soon as possible before we lose
everything
Jack Arnold is a jtf specialist and was
the squad leader for Proteus task force
Proteus was established to scour the
streets of DC and scavenge any supplies
they could find after several weeks the
Convoy came across Kenley College
Unfortunately they weren't the first
ones to visit the campus the outcasts
had set up camp there and it wasn't long
before task force Proteus found
themselves in the middle of an ambush bu
the outcasts killed 99% of the jtf in
the Convoy and looted the supplies
including military grade servers
encrypted radio handsets chemicals
explosives a jtf prisoner and a mobile
shd server Jack would be one of the
lucky few who survived but as a hostage
she'll be forced to build improvised
explosive devices for the
outcasts agents would eventually go on
to rescue Jack from Kinley college and
reunite them with their partner Mel
since returning to DC jack is been
monitoring Intel collected by the mobile
Le HD server whilst also managing the
Castle's food
storage I don't know why they followed
us Mel said you took a mobile shade
server yeah so we can stay in contact
with your agents it's how I send the
distress call but I think we were out of
range the network went down we had to
get it back up and running before we got
the call what did I miss too much I
can let Mel fill you in later what
happened to the agent who sent us to
Kenley agent yeah yeah he was supposed
to meet us there but he never showed he
told us to bring the server do you
remember his name uh John Tom Richardson
honestly I don't remember it was a
pretty generic white boy name no worries
we can check the logs are we done here
yeah can I go see Mel now I asked them
to meet us here thank you anything else
I should know about other than the
network going down oh not much agents
recover president Ellis the hyenas had
him he tried to Stage a military coup
he's with the black task it's
complicated in a post-rescue briefing
with Manny Jack explains that they had
an shd server on them so they could keep
in contact with the division of course
this was at a time when the full shd
Network had been taken down so no one
back at the base of operations received
the distress call Jack had obviously
been held captive for quite some time as
she was oblivious to all of the major
events that have been playing out one
interesting thing she mentions here is
that it was an agent who sent task force
Proteus to Kenley and if we remember
from Mel's rescue many had no idea why
and who sent them there so this agent
while still in DC was working completely
separately to the team our agents have
been working with up until now on top of
this it was him who told her to bring
the server yet he never showed up when
the outcasts brung their trap Jack
wasn't able to name the agent but I
would place a fairly solid bet on it
being someone who we've only recently
started interacting with but why he
would do this I don't know I have my
suspicions but I'll talk about that a
little bit later
on hey Manny thanks for meeting with me
you wanted to show me something yeah
when we turned the mobile shade server
back on we recovered some files they
seemed important and maybe something you
wouldn't want everyone to know about
what kind of files recordings mostly
conversations between a defense
contractor and someone named Cal do you
have them with you I copied part of one
over before we had to charge the server
when we turned it back on the original
recordings were gone and there was new
Intel someone talking about a play it
was weird the server must have been
damaged back at Kenley can we hear the
one you have sure it's not much but this
is what we managed to record before the
battery died well I know our pockets
aren't as deep as yours hopefully you'll
play nice in the bidding war today oh
Cal I don't want to start a war with you
sorry I know it's not much but it seemed
important if it was on the server thanks
than Jack honestly I don't know what to
do with that but if you get any more
files try and record them before you
reboot the server we'll
do Jack provides Manny an update on the
mobile shd server she's having trouble
collecting information and suspects it
may have been damaged at Kinley as it
only has partial messages and some are
being lost after rebooting for anyone
not aware that one part that was played
was actually the very first descent coms
that drops it's Kelvin mcmanis and
Natalia soov meeting with Ortiz robotics
to discuss the new AI they've been
working on
Isaac the other one she mentioned about
a play is actually another one we hear
later on that is part of a number of
discussions between Kelvin and an NSA
analyst who discovered early signs of
concern regarding Gordon
Amherst another recording yeah we've got
a name on the mystery woman great let's
hear it Natalia
sakova as I live and breathe Cal is it
wrong that I expected you to die in the
first wave not at all Nat most of my
colleagues and those bureaucrats did you
think being a ground zero would have
been a death sentence turns out I had
the infrastructure in place to weather
the storm well I'm glad to see your
thriving given the conditions you're not
doing too bad yourself Nat I'm not how's
our boy officially installed as
president since Mendes was taken care of
good good and now presumed dead since
Air Force 1 crashed and we never
recovered his body presumed dead or
confirmed dead presumed I've got him
squirel away until he's ready to play
ball he forgot his place in this
organization and started to make some
decisions on his own can't have the
puppets doing the puppeteering
exactly Jack manages to extract another
recording this one is from after the
outbreak and the first wave have been
activated and subsequently fell Kelvin
actually confirms that most of his
colleagues and the political in the
White House have fallen to the green
poison and that he is one of the last
ones left this actually answers a few
questions around where he is currently
sitting in the presidential line of
succession in present day this comms
also confirms that he is well aware and
involved in the black task having taken
care of the former president in order to
place Ellis in his place it would appear
that this is around the time where Ellis
was having second thoughts about his
Allegiance with Natalia which actually
wasn't too long before fa Lao had him
killed Calvin and Natalia have been
working on this for a long time she was
surprised he wasn't Dead from the
outbreak but they certainly seemed to
have been planning this for a
while agents receive Intel that jaet
could be being held at the Washington
Monument in the West pomac Park District
of
DC calling in for jtf support they
stormed the control point there they
find the Monument riddled with true sun
and Black Tusk
soldiers once cleared the hostiles would
attempt a Counterattack but this would
prove fruitless as the agents hunkered
down and picked them off at range
although Jack was nowhere to be seen on
site a hostile coms that was intercepted
would tell the agents that Jack has
recently been at the medical
Camp
keep hostile radio
intercepted look where are they taking
us the medical Camp what why who knows
maybe to make sure we're not infected
maybe to feed us to the Troops they look
hungry Vic is not
funny rogue agent
detected after dispatching a surprised
group of Rogues who are taking advantage
of the distraction agents would quickly
move Northwest of their
[Music]
position tracking down Target Vladimir
monk Davis the agents hope to intercept
the Black Tusk movements before they
once again are able to move Jack to
another location fighting through his
henchmen and sniper doggos they would
eventually meet up with them in the
center of a long since abandoned Sarah
Camp while his bodyguards proved to be a
little tougher than they had anticipated
the agents fought through and would pick
up and another hostile
Communications hostile radio
where's Vick don't worry about him he's
someone else's problem now I'm not going
to lie the Mast is a hell of a lot more
peaceful without him here sorry
Vic confirmed I've got eyes on Jack at
the
Mast while they were once gained too
late the mass control Point wasn't far
away so they wasted no time moving
[Music]
on the agents once again called in for
support from the jtf unfortunately this
time they seem to be get a little bit
distracted by something that was
obviously more important on the streets
outside of the compound so the agents
were on their
own finding a favorable position
overlooking the entrances they were able
to lock down the area and pick off any
incoming
hostiles once eliminated agent Johnson
could be heard over the air
[Music]
pieces agent we track ja to the site of
Crash drone we'll get you the
[Applause]
[Music]
coordinates after Johnson sent through
the coordinates the agents wasted no
time in moving and forcing their hand of
which they really brought something to
the table that they certainly weren't
expecting a
crap moving through the drone crash site
they would meet heavy Black Tusk
resistance which would have the agents
questioning the gear they chose to use
in this hunt but regardless they pushed
through
it wouldn't be long before the main
hostile Target in the area would be
spotted and after effortlessly disposing
of the Black Tusk soldiers they would
take him down once again being allerted
by agent Johnson to a new location that
Jack was last
spotted I need to swap this
over agent we've located Jack Arnold at
Capital
Hill Jack Arnold last known location was
at the Hostile stronghold of Capital
Hill rushing on in there the agents find
themselves surrounded on multiple sides
perhaps the less than stealthy apparel
that ched to wear was working against
them Jack's still pretty messed up after
what happened at kley college but she's
found her footing since the outcasts
abducted
her leading up towards the capital
building they were met with huge
resistance including headshot stack
destroying warhounds but they pushed
through with Superior drone surveillance
and accuracy deep into the building they
found themselves completely encircled by
Black Tusk forces but while ducking in
and out of cover taking pinpoint shots
on their opponents which actually means
very little because they were using the
extremely overpowered determin Talent
they were able to force the Hostile
command out of their
entrenchment the Black Tusk leader spent
more time announcing their presence in
the fight than firing her weapon and the
Agents would in turn be awarded by
another exotic component to be added to
the resource pole after clearing out the
rest of of the opposition the agents
would learn that Brian Johnson and the
jtf have managed to extract Jack and
take her back to the
castle area
secure I'll get Jack back to the castle
nice work
[Music]
agent what's wrong with the server you
should really go find Mel they're
worried sick about you I will as soon as
you tell me what the hell is going on
with the server it's having trouble
connecting to the network range is
spotty like something is interfering
with it maybe overloading it since when
since the attack no since we got maray
back who's working on it Cindy and
Wall-E Brian said he'd take a look but I
honestly don't know how much help he can
be we fixed it the server was stable
there was nothing wrong with it are you
sure it started acting up after Mari
came back it was fun that night and then
in the morning it started acting up
anything else strange happened nothing
really agent Johnson came back but he's
been trying to help us fix it maybe it
was damaged in the attack we just didn't
notice after Jack's second rescue Manny
catches up with her for a debrief sadly
for her husband Mel she is more
concerned about the mobile shd server
and what's happening with it but this is
obviously because she's more than aware
of the potentially valuable Intel it
holds that she's already almost lost her
life to
while it looks like there are connection
issues it was pointed out and then
confirmed that this only started
happening after Mari Singh was rescued
and brought back home in her absence
Cindy Wally and even agent Johnson have
been working on
AIX Jack proclaims that it was working
fine before the attack and then her
capture so why would it start acting up
now after Mari got back and this is a
fair question but I don't think Mari has
anything to do with it as it was also
during this time that agent Johnson
suddenly appeared do I think this is
related yes I absolutely do but let's
get back to this in a
second it's been a while yeah sorry
about that been busy setting up the farm
and the food storage we haven't done a
sync on the server in a while what did
you
find Nat I'd like you to meet the
recruiter the recruiter from my hunter's
replacement he's going to be responsible
for Bonnie's test make sure he's as good
as you say he is and ready to join our
little organization
right nice to meet you Mr
recruiter Hunters have been instructed
not to speak you never know who's
listening and what kind of voice
recognition software they have running
you're paranoid Cal rather be paranoid
than wrong well you've made it this far
without being discovered so maybe there
is something to your methods Cal that's
quite the compliment coming from you Nat
you get this man to a fair day cage and
you can get to know him better until
then please inform your black task to
only address my agent as the
recruiter this piece of Intel is much
closer to present day where Jack has
long since been recovered from Kenley
college and has fully taken on a new
role in the castle sedent the comms talk
about Natalia being introduced to the
recruiter before our first viewing of
him where Bonnie was being tested to see
whether he was suitable for the hunter
program there isn't anything huge to
dissect here but it does answer a few of
the much theories I've seen floating
around about the hunters we're now
learning why the hunters don't talk it's
not that they can't it's that they
shouldn't so there is a lot to process
here when I was told by The Narrative
director that I would enjoy what this
rescue would bring to our attention she
absolutely wasn't wrong at this stage at
least through what I'm seeing it would
be fair to have all fingers pointed
agent Johnson right now while I do
believe he is playing a part in
sabotaging the mobile shd server I'm not
completely convinced that he is the
recruiter I can't even give any solid
reason for this it's just that something
doesn't quite add up for me here I just
see him as a soldier who's extremely
loyal to Kelvin Kelvin has implanted
within to help with removing any proof
that he can get his hands on that shows
certain interactions that may paint
Kelvin in a less than favorable light he
mentioned that most of his colleagues
have been taken out by the green poison
and now that Alis is did he could be the
next in
line being Rogue doesn't mean what it
used to and it's looking more now that
instead we have two groups of Agents
fighting for two different
sides technically we could be the Rogues
because we aren't reporting to any sort
of authority where Brian Johnson is
potentially reporting to the
president but how does it change
everything if we know that the president
got there through let's say far less
than ethical
means it's definitely a save what it
remains and desperate times call for
desperate measures type
situation however I feel there could be
a slight turn in our favor coming up in
a couple of weeks time will be unmasking
the recruiter given the help that he
provided Mari during her rescue will he
be our we
in some of these man hunts are so rich
with information that I feel like I need
to start breaking them down into several
smaller more easy to digest videos
rather than perhaps making them a little
more concise than I'd like to I really
like how the Descent comms are being fed
into the story not that they weren't
telling a story before just that we were
suddenly receiving them for no reason
while playing descent it's only a small
thing but these are the dumb questions
that keep me up at
night how is everyone feeling about the
recruiter coming up in 2 weeks I know
agent Johnson is a favorite across the
board but like I said I still feel like
it's someone else maybe it's the widely
missed Alex from the division one
writers are there any other suggestions
out there let us all know in the
comments I love seeing the speculation
anyway thank you very much for watching
and extremist MS extremer
remedia
[Music]
[Applause]